I came to Britain in the late 1960s and we lived in Huddersfield.
When I got married, I moved up to Glasgow.
This is an area called Westwood which is about 15 miles out of Glasgow City center.
It's a very peaceful area, as you can see. It's surrounded by hills.
The kind of life I lead, the kind of life our family leads is perfect.
I really enjoy living here.
Those who came from the rural backgrounds of the Punjab, whether it was India or Pakistan,...
...came really looking for a better economic life.
I suppose those people who continue to live within a community context feel that they need that around them...
...because it gives them an identity, a safety and a cultural context.
Most British people don't have any objection to people living in the communities that they choose to live in.
The very fact that people are being allowed to live in this way...
...is a reflection of the kind of laissez-faire attitude of the British;...
...that as long as you're law-abiding, everybody is entitled to live the kind of life they want.
I think there may be a silent expectation that people who migrate to this country take part in this country.
But I don't think there's any expectation at all that people give up their faith.
You know, we have over two million Muslims living in the UK.
I think most of them are very happy to be living here irrespective of what's happening in the global scene.
I came into academia largely through a scholarship I received at Manchester University.
And from then on, Islamic studies and Islamic law became my main research area.
Law is theology. Law is thinking. Law is ethics.
This country does allow you opportunities.
Nobody is going to force you to take any opportunities,...
...nobody is going to get in your way if you want to take opportunities.
If you have a goal and if you're prepared to work hard, you can achieve whatever you want to achieve in this country.
And I think that that's the kind of ethos I want to instill in my own children.
This isn't a society that's going to force you in any direction.
But on the other hand, if you do take opportunities and you do try and better yourself,...
...as well as trying to better the society around you, people appreciate that and people do help you along that journey.
But in the end, the journey is for you to make and no one can make that journey for you.